we are following the very latest
developments near boulder city right now
where
five people are dead after a crash
involving a group of bicyclists
this happened on u.s 95 at nelson road
there are traffic impacts as well
hector mejia live on scene with the very
latest hi hector
hey there alex we're still standing by
for an update from nhp but they confirm
five people dead four others injured one
of them critically and earlier this
morning a viewer reached out to me
through twitter telling me
that her family was traveling northbound
on us-95 and they saw the scene of the
crash they described it as
several bicycles just scattered in the
roadway on us-95
southbound and that is where we're
standing right now this is the
southbound side of us-95 this is
nelson road this is where the closure is
this is where nhp and ndot
are diverting traffic away from the
scene of the crash and off to the right
that is where the scene is several
several miles away from us at least 10
miles away
the southern nevada bicycle coalition
told my colleague kristen drummond
that this was actually a birthday
bicycle right a group of people
celebrating a birthday
they were planning on traveling about
130 miles from the m resort down to
searchlight
then to nipton and then the plans were
to go back to the m resort but that did
not happen
uh this crash here uh the people that
were hurt in the crash were told
uh they were advanced level cyclists and
we were also told that there was a
support vehicle with them kind of like a
car driving behind them
kind of like an added safety measure but
something went wrong and according to
nhp
this crash involved a box truck and
several bicycles
along us-95 southbound lanes near
boulder city and now as you can see
drivers trying to get through off in the
distance it looks like so my big rigs
are just camping out
and telling drivers that this road at
least for the southbound lanes are
expected to stay closed for at least
eight to ten hours reporting live hector
mejia
8 news now alex back to you